let's talk about crybaby antifa yes so
so the first thing i want to ask you is
uh
you have been on the ground covering
stuff i can imagine you've been
threatened by antifa
they talk big game right physically
assaulted threatened
called all kinds of stuff a white
supremacist the list goes on you're one
hispanic
last name last name ends with a z
uh just try and wrap your mind around
that one guys so
so so they talk big game they talk but
uh uh
you were saying earlier that when they
get arrested all of a sudden that's what
police have told me it's
but are they saying they just clam up
and like quiet up because they know they
need lawyers
they're they're just this is how it was
described to me
they're just nice little kids very
polite
not not not chanting the vile chants
anymore just
very nice very polite so weird they just
they just walk right out
when they're when they're let out that's
so weird that's how it was no because
because i like this story check this out
this is from the new york post antifa
commander with a flame flower
burst into tears during arrest cops said
i love everything about this
this is just so inflamed the tears
he's got a flame thrower he's called
commander red
dude this is man
how old is this guy he's 23. you know
when i was i was like
how old i think i was like seven years
old and there was a nintendo game called
mighty bomb jack yeah
and i took a garbage bag i was a little
kid and i was jumping up and down and i
jumped off the
my bed and i slammed my leg on the bed
post and i started screaming and crying
that's exactly what this is but i was
like seven when that happened it's a
true story mind you
my mom will attest to this they do this
i have so many clips
and and and i do this a lot and this is
probably why they want to kill me
but i think about it i put little i put
little uh
you know i compile clips back to back to
back of just antifa
super cut just getting pwned you know
just just totally screaming squealing
crying
and it's just but a lot of people don't
understand like when you see the footage
of police tear gassing or using you know
non-lethal munitions
they always post that but they never
post the beginning
exactly where they're antagonizing
police sometimes for hours and you know
this i'm not
you already know this but i don't know
whatever yeah people that are listening
they will antagonize for hours
hours just all kinds of vile obscenities
racist racist racist throwing multiple
cocktails
they bait them they bait them they bait
them and then the police come out and
respond and that's what antifa
i've i've i've seen some stuff from cops
that is absolutely objectionable
i have seen uh instances where in
ferguson a cop walked right up and just
out of there was no conflict there was
no fighting and just one cop just threw
a flashbang at a bunch of random people
and that sparked chaos
there's that that incident in uh oakland
back during the occupy era
where this dude got shot in the head
with i think it was a bean bag or a tear
gas canister and it gave him brain
damage
and he fell down and when people ran in
to try and help him a cop chucked a
flashbang
into the crowd of people cops aren't
perfect no they're not
however however what people need to
understand about a lot of these clips is
that
yes i think reform is a good thing i
think those cops should be held
accountable
and we need to absolutely have a review
of the use of force because we're in
power we're entrusting
these these people who go out there to
do the right thing
and to try and keep us safe but what
they don't tell you is that oftentimes
these people go out with great
intentions the cops
and then some antifa walk up to a black
cop and start screaming
every possible racial slur they can
think of dude
i don't know if you saw the video from
the portland ice
where a bunch of white dudes were
screaming just
man some of these racial slurs that they
were screaming at these guys
and bravo to these cops who kept their
cool did their job and did the right
thing
but this is why like you said earlier
just so people can connect the dots
this is why they'll come out and say you
don't film us only
exactly that's exactly why yep yeah dude
there was there was another
a recent viral video this auntie for
women screaming at a black woman
of like racist stuff about white
supremacy and then some guy very calmly
says to this screeching white woman
you're screaming at a black woman don't
you think there's something wrong with
that and her eyes are like
bugged out and she's like no i'm the
only one who can speak because i'm white
demoralized i this is this is this is
crazy right
we definitely got to talk about
commander red i'm not i'm not forgetting
commander red okay
we're talking about the flamethrower
there right yeah he gave himself a code
name and all that stuff
oh man think about what it means
when you have a white woman screaming
i'm the only one or things to that
effect
these these are white progressives who
are being told
by avowed racists like the robin
d'angelo and white fragility
that here's what you need to do have a
white racial awakening
and form a white collective to improve
the betterment of the poor minorities
that's their message dude that that i'm
like what's
what's the difference between that and
like i don't know like white
supremacists
you're gonna go out and claim that you
are the one who has to do everything
because you were the white person with
privilege
yeah it just sounds like good old white
supremacy to me extreme steps i mean
with extra steps i've seen the the xkjb
right yeah yeah oh yeah we get everybody
dude
like that we're living that right now
totally the first step of subversion
right demoralization that's already
completed yeah we're in the process
right now
of destabilization and i think uh panic
right now in crisis yeah that's what he
taught and right now
i mean that was decades ago but the
first thing
two things to go during subversion was
religion and education those are the two
things that education's gone
that's where we are and there's multiple
media all that stuff but right now i
think we are definitely
living through that i just had a really
horrifying thought oh no
let's hear it the sea you see this guy
right here look at those eyes
this is this is commander red okay there
he is
the horrifying thought was like we're
sitting here laughing and we're like
look at this [ __ ]
yeah and then in 20 years he's pulling
the cord on the guillotine
and he's got like a rugged beard and
he's all ripped and he's like remember
that episode
okay 126. tim cass diarrheal september
2nd 2020 and i'm like
did that no i wouldn't be crying i'd be
like bring it call me
spit in his face get my head chopped off
send me to heaven i'm ready right yeah
he like looks in the basket in the last
split second of life i go yeah i spit
blood on him
okay that's a little gruesome but let's
read let's read it commander red
yes an antifa leader known as commander
red
was busted carrying a flame thrower
to a wisconsin black lives matter rally
and dropped into the
fetal position and began crying yep
yeah sounds about right dude countless
times yeah man
matthew banta 23 is known to be a
violent antifa member who incites
violence and otherwise relatively
peaceful protests a criminal complaint
in his green bay arrest record insisted
according to wbay
he was carrying stickers and a flag for
the controversial group
the name of the name of which is short
for anti-fascist along with
military-grade five-minute smoke
grenades
fireworks rockets and a flamethrower
how did he get a flame was he are we
talking like a like one of those boring
company elon musk flamethrowers
i really want to know because those ones
aren't that strong
yeah but like did he have a real they
say
bantu was stopped at uh stopped her
being spotted with a whole bunch of
white people with sticks baseball bats
and helmets
the lm event in green bay police said
the criminal complaint
the others fled when a cop blocked them
with his squad car but bantu was stopped
and dropped into the fetal position and
began crying
the police report said he complained
that the officer got on top of him which
police denied
it's worrisome when people associated
with antifa come here to green bay from
out of town
for the purposes of committing violent
acts green bay police chief andrew smith
told the station
at the time of saturday's arrest banta
was out on ten thousand dollars cash
bond after being
accused of pointing a loaded gun wait
what
appointing a loaded gun at a police
officer whoa as well as biting and
kicking a cop at a protest earlier this
month the report said
a condition of his bond was that he
can't have a dangerous weapon according
to the brown county district attorney's
office oh wow wonderful
was dangerous weapons geez the 23 year
old from nina about 40 miles south of
green bay was charged with obstructing
an officer and two counts of felony bail
jumping
after saturday's arrest the report said
he was released late monday on 2500
bond court records show how did this guy
get released he's
they literally 500 bucks they literally
arrested him for jumping bail
oh my god and they're like let's let him
go how about it brother
what i'm saying investigations
investigations sir yeah
as he's walking out of the police
station sir one your flame thrower
you almost left it behind oh man and
he's literally apologizing
we apologize for using force uh you know
but uh
you're free to go here's the thing yeah
here's all your weapons
here's your flamethrower to use on us in
the next eight hours yeah like the guy
at the desk of the department pulls up a
big box and he goes let's see we've got
uh one
loaded glock nine millimeter that's
what's what's this oh we got a
flamethrower
that's your flamethrower and a couple
cans of kerosene i don't know if they
use grenades
yeah a couple smoke bombs and uh there
you go sir have a nice day
we'll see here's your receipt for the
bill yep here's what they say here's
what ends they say he was one of 15
arrested at saturday's black lives
matter protest that turned violent in
the city
and was deemed an unlawful assembly
burning buildings hurting people
shooting looting vandalizing there's
absolutely no way
that is a form of protest this that's
criminal behavior
you know what this article proves it
proves a couple things
look at this guy uh this dude he he
doesn't
i'm i'm sorry man it doesn't look like
he's he's it doesn't look like he's
lifted a heavy object in his life and
save the flamethrower that is not an
hour i don't know
sure he gave himself a code name
right he's larping yeah but they don't
realize they're actually hurting people
yeah
or like it's crazy you know if you want
a larp
you go you get one of those pool noodles
from like the pool shop and you put a
stick in it congratulations you got you
got a staff you can you can hit your
friends it doesn't hurt
it's very difficult to actually
seriously hurt somebody with that i
guess you could fall on it or something
but this guy somehow got a flamethrower
like who how did he get a flamethrower
these guys man they are funded you know
um it's like you said
they it's really easy for them to
crowdsource exactly even in portland and
i was saying this earlier before we
started the podcast is
a lot of the locals support these guys
that was interesting oh definitely
they really like when i was uh when i
was on the ground when they kicked
that dude in the head that night when i
was reporting that entire night before
they kicked him in the head
this elderly couple and you see it in
the video they
show up and i look to the side and i'm
like hey you guys need to get out of
here they're like
no we're going to box them in we're
going to box them in they get out of the
car and they're like ready to beat them
up
people are nuts dude these elderly
portland residents
they have no idea what's going on that's
why it's like
some of the some of the some of the
locals have bought in
to the lie and they support them that's
true yeah
some journalists have actually been
documenting that and i think i need to
do a better job of document documenting
that too because that's
it's part of the story i think you know
i was reading about
civil war because there's been a there
have been an endless stream of these
articles popping up over the past
several years just
escalating as things get crazier and
crazier there's an article from vox
saying something like what would it take
to convince you to change your mind on
donald trump
and they basically concluded that nobody
will
because the tribal lines are so distinct
and so far apart
there's no way to convince someone
otherwise
and the crazy thing is i know for a fact
that these leftists are lying and are
wrong and i think
many people do but there are people who
don't care
it's like i i it almost feels like a bit
of a cliche to say this but a split
between two tribes of logic versus
emotion
you've got one side that includes
liberals conservatives moderates all of
a sudden now you've got
liberals wanting to vote for trump and
on the left you have people who
who you can't reason with yeah i mean
for sure there are trump supporters that
you can't reason with
but i can sit down and have a
conversation with 99.9
of trump supporters and argue for like
left-wing policy positions
and and the example i often use is like
when i was talking to glenn beck about
pro-life versus pro-choice
we ended with a smile and a hand jack
and that was a great conversation and uh
come on by any time you you too man i
appreciate it was good
good fun and that that's about it yep on
the left you don't get that
you get elderly couples pulling up in
cars yelling get them get them box them
in and there's like some dude
they're trying to kill for no reason he
was trying to save somebody
that's the level of insane zealotry well
we we've been subverted
we've been successfully demoralized as a
culture especially millennials and i
think alongside of that it makes sense
because that dude that xkjb dude said
once that happens
it's impossible to change their mind you
can show them the truth
yeah you could take them to a gulag in
the soviet union you could take them to
north korea and show them what their
ideas look like
nationwide and they still won't change
their mind and that's a dangerous place
to be because
it's a matter of ideology all these
ideologies all these anti-fascist
ideologies that have subverted so many
people
they've poisoned so many people
and the propaganda is powerful i think
the turning point
was charlottesville and this is why
because the way propaganda works
is the media whoever it is they'll put
out a lie
of what they want people to believe
years in advance
we saw that with cnn trump is a racist
trump is a white supremacist
trump sides with nazis trump this trump
that there was no evidence
right they'll put out the narrative with
no evidence and then
when some time goes on and the slightest
thing happens
like charlottesville even though it's a
lie the slightest thing happens
we told you so right we told you so and
the nation
is in an uproar the lie was already set
up
the slightest little bit of it's not
even evidence but the slightest thing
they capitalize on it it's that version
it's happening again subversion
joe biden came out and said trump's you
know
violent militia invading these cities
and the proud boys announced they're
going to portland yep
just like uh uh what's that refuse
fascism
right you well you know they're who
who's behind them right who exactly
revcom refcom right yeah
yeah exactly revcom their message have
always been trump is a fascist
mike pence is a fascist fascist fascist
fascist with zero evidence
for years for years and now all of a
sudden
trump calls dhs into portland what's
what's
pelosi saying secret police storm
troopers storm troopers yeah
boom well that batteries that all
backfired on them yeah and now they're
in panic like joe biden rushing out of
his basement to go to kenosha
after he said he wouldn't do it they're
hurting and they know it they know
regular people have been like
you can't keep telling us these are
peaceful protests when someone smashed
out the window of my local barber shop
yep it's not peaceful yeah and and
burned down our car dealership
right yeah i'm i'm telling you i think
if there's one thing that can make trump
lose his election it's the proud boys
going to portland
it could be a possibility and i'll say
it again the election fraud is is deep
oh for sure for sure yeah and i i always
want to make sure i preface this
because there's a lot of people who
might not have heard the other segments
i've done on it but dr burks and dr
fauci have both said we can safely vote
in person
done yet for some reason democrats are
like nah nah we're not you know we're
gonna we're gonna vote by mail anyway so
there's no reason to change the rules
but what really is worrisome to me is
everything you just explained i see it
happening right now yeah
they are now claiming that trump's
militias are invading towns yep
the proud boys then announced they're
going to do their march through portland
antifa is going to be lying in wait in
the shadows to instigate something
and they're going to have their allied
photographers antepa is going to throw a
water balloon or something
and the proud boy is going to swing and
they're going to wait and time it
perfectly and you're going to get
dude getting punched by proud boy it's
going to be on the front page of every
paper
trump's violent supporters the rise of
the brown shirts
we already saw this one tweet they got
102 000 retweets probably more by now
yeah then it was like it's about time we
read the history of the nazi brown
shirts invading left-wing areas and
starting violence
then claiming only they could solve the
violence as if that's what's happening
it's not no
but that that's why i'm i'm i'm like
look again first and foremost if you
want to peacefully protest fine go do it
but i can only assume like they re they
have to realize
and to go to your point we've talked
about this me and the guys you know we
we when we're reporting when we go
somewhere
we're fully aware that there's
propaganda floating around the usa that
some of these things
could possibly be staged now i'm not
like this crazy conspiracy theorist but
i'm fully aware that something could be
taking place and i could be baited just
to go in
and get footage and and that's kind of
where we are in the journalist reporting
game right now
is we have to be very careful are we
being baited into something
are the proud boys being baited into
something is it gonna like you're saying
and i think i i agree with you i think
it could very well be something
uh that could be used as propaganda
continued propaganda
to fuel uh the left's narrative of trump
being the
the fourth reich commander and you know
it's too late
the moment it was announced they were
doing it even if they try and backpedal
now
all it takes is for some you know
someone to just
find anybody who's like a trump
supporter yeah because people are gonna
go
and then they're gonna be like there's
you know look look we just saw what
happened in portland
and right now the craziest thing to me
is that
first of all the friend of the victim of
the guy who got killed in portland the
trump supporter got executed
has said law enforcement needs to handle
this donald trump has said law
enforcement needs to handle this
yeah trump's trump and his supporters
have won the moral high ground for now
saying that we're not you know don't go
out don't retaliate
you can't have any of this street-level
stuff escalating and the police will
take care of it
and now you get this announcement that
they're going to go down there and i'm
like oh yeah that's that's exactly what
the left was hoping for
they knew that this crazy guy who shot
this dude made them look really really
bad
it's just like what happened with andy
no when they physically
you know beat up andy and left him
bleeding from the mouth and ears
there was no way to ignore that story
everybody was sharing the video
everybody was asking about it and the
media went
into a panic yeah and i say the media
but many outlets like local adults are
fine when they cover this stuff but a
lot of these like lefty progressive vc
funded digital outlets were like
actually and you know is a fascist and
and and
and i ran with it but but most people it
didn't it didn't work yeah and the
reason antifa
went into panic mode and then they
published that video accusing andy now
of secretly organizing with
you know white supremacists because he
was walking next to them at some point
yeah the stupidest thing ever and they
weren't white supremacist anyway
they they they're doing that as damage
control yep right now we've got a video
that appears to show a far leftist the
black lives matter tattoo on his neck
executing a trump supporter minding his
own business that you
now you know if you if you want trump to
win you sit back and you say please
trump do something about this
but these rallies men i think it'll lead
to uh
propagandistic efforts of uh i mean it
could be theoretically be another
another charlottesville
because we had what was it uh like in
the 20th or 22nd or whatever
when when right-wing groups and
left-hand groups clashed yeah were
you were you there at all no it was not
where was the last place you went to
uh dc was the last place that i've been
to oh right for that
i was in kenosha yeah yeah i was in
kenosha i broke that story
kenosha's kind of chilled out though
isn't it it's chilled out now thank god
because that place was torched yeah
literally torched dude like
it's sad you know when i i interviewed i
was there the first night i was i was
there the first night
when i showed up they were already
torching everything and then when i went
back to interview some of the locals
they were just
they all kept saying the same thing i
never thought
that something like this could ever
happen in my home like this
and i'm like dude no one no one is safe
no you could put black lives matter on
your business but if they're feeling
like it that
night doesn't matter you can even be a
black person
like they did in portland the other
night they started to burn down a black
owned business
yep and it's on film they don't care
they don't care it doesn't
they don't care and they'll you could be
a random person walking down the street
and they could just look at you and yell
so there's a video from germany
there's a reporter i know he's just a
reporter and someone pointed at him and
yelled
nazi schweinhund i think that's the word
i don't speak german nazi pig
yeah and they just beat him up and they
grabbed his camera from him and he's
like i have no idea what's happening and
they're screaming you're a nazi you're
it's like
i'm an american journalist i have no
idea what's happening and then someone
intervened
he eventually like he put his hands up
and started saying no no i'm not a nazi
i'm not a nazi
and then someone convinced the other guy
to give his camera back and then they're
like leave
yeah all it takes is if you see the mob
of antifa
in any any location if someone points at
you and says nazi
they'll start running and screaming
towards you and they will beat the crap
out of you they will burn your car down
they'll flip your car over they don't
care yep they don't know work here
if you're not in a group of people if
they are outnumbering you
that's definitely going to happen to you
i just want to give an example
to people of how how insane they are
i was in la i was documenting a protest
a gathering it was the trump supporters
in antifa
i was standing with antifa and i was
recording them
they were screaming and they were
yelling out nazi scum
nazi scum you're all nazis to
trump supporting jews let's start with
star of david flags
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay and i know
that's not a surprise to you
but people that are listening it's it's
not that they honestly
they do believe that but it's gotten to
the point where it's just a smear
tactic to have an excuse to go and hurt
somebody
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you